I remember when I was re I'd done
something wrong and I was really I'd
completely [__] up and I was so upset
and I was expecting my dad to sort of
come and go you know Ben everything's
gonna be all right and he just sat there
and he went what are you going to do
about it I don't want someone just to
sit there and straighten my ego and tell
me that everything's gonna be okay and
I'm okay the way I am because I think
that over a prolonged period of time can
definitely lead to entitlement I think
it can lead to softness and weakness and
I don't think it's the right thing in
the long term
Ben Francis welcome to the show thank
you for having me you have had the
fortune of speaking to some of the best
operators on the planet what are the
common threads the most common traits
that you found between all of the high
performance that you've spoken to I felt
like this is the obvious one so they're
very organized I feel like there's the
basics right organized articular
intelligent the things that you'd expect
of anyone who's a great operator
I also think that they tend to be better
people than what you think for the most
part I feel like there's this view that
there's this evil group of people that
sit and control the world in a way and
I'm you know that might well be true for
all for all all I know but certainly in
the people that have run some of the
really successful businesses they tend
to be really really great people and
great individuals and really really
helpful
and a lot of those people have really
helped me and there's um
I mean people will know that Jim shark
has had a great relationship with
Shopify for a long long time and Toby
And particularly Harley who run that
business have been endlessly helpful to
both me as an individual I mean even
other people that work in the business
but our business as well
um and I think
Harley really resonated with me and he
continues to resonate with me because he
is such a good human being and the fact
that he has such a well-balanced work
life but also home life I think is
that's really interesting to me and it's
been massively inspiring what's an
example of Harley's work and home life
showing up in a way that you found
inspirational
well that was a few I mean there's many
but the first and foremost I think this
is going to sound so basic and some of
these are going to sound so trivial but
he's always happy to see you like which
is which is really cool right and I
think he remembers people's names and
there's those sorts of comment traits
and he will not remember this by any
stretch of the imagination but we were
working in Germany a few years ago a few
years ago this was pre-covered now
um and I think there was something
particularly had to do with like say 9pm
or something like that we've been
working through the day with like the
talks and the events and all that and
then everyone went for food after there
was probably a table of 12 or so people
um but I knew that he had had to get off
by let's say nine o'clock
and he was actually it was a really good
conversation it was a really good chat I
think everyone was really interested in
him because it was a lot of shopify's
largest Merchants there and literally
like clockwork at 8 59 he stands up
shakes everyone's hand he knows
everyone's name and he heads off and he
goes to bed and just sort of carries on
with his day and that level of
efficiency albeit to him which is
probably just something that was so
basic and normal to me that was that was
really that was really interesting
because it would have been so easy to
stay another 30 minutes another 45
minutes and another hour and I know the
things that you wanted to do by the way
is he wanted to get off because he
wanted to speak to his family and he
wanted to prepare for the next day and I
think those little things over a
prolonged period of time really add up
and and being able to watch him and
observe him do that I think was
interesting
um and listen it's similar of other
people there's um there's a guy who's
based in London that runs I think it
might be the world's biggest digital
marketing agency a company called akqa a
guy called a jars
who is just like a really really good
human being and he just he he seems to
maintain relationships with people over
a really really long period of time
and that doesn't happen on accident and
by the way bad people in my experience
aren't able to maintain relationships
with people for really prolonged periods
of time so
having met lots of different people I
would say I've definitely been
pleasantly surprised with the fact that
they generally tend to be good people
rather than bad people we were talking
about this before we started this
conversation I had with homozy where he
said that
uh ego will keep you poor rather than
make you rich and and you know man you
know a lot of the people that I spend
time with the operators that are slick
and that are able to do it over a long
enough period of time
by Design if you're a prick to everyone
you'll get found out yeah
I really believe that and I think
there's there's this other thing as well
and again just to put into context is
Shopify is a business that
I don't know it must be 40 times 50
times bigger than gymshark minimum I
don't know what it's revenues I don't
know what its revenues are but it's I
know it's it's just vastly vastly bigger
than Jim shark
and you know we might never ever be at
the site the size or scale that they are
and I'm sure I've got a very limited
amount of information that I can give to
someone like Harley that he hasn't
already heard from people that are far
more intelligent articulate remembering
that Harley and Toby's company is the
company that facilitates your company
right yeah exactly do you all like the
grandchild of the Shopify business yeah
they might I don't I don't know that if
they're not then they're one of the
biggest Employers in Canada
but I feel like every time that we're
talking he is trying to learn something
from me and I'm trying to learn
something from you there's not this
whole thing of our areas here's small
fry I know everything it's that
mentality of always being open to
learning I thought and it always
surprises me it's the same with the jars
as well it's always like what you see
and what you're interested in what
excites you what mistakes have you made
and then I'll obviously talk them
through that and they'll sort of help me
out and give me feedback but
this consistent
way of being open-minded as well I think
that's really fascinating talk to me
about the problems that you have of
being a person with opinions who has a
private life who has a Mrs who now has a
pair of twins congratulations
uh and and you have insights and Views
around the world and yet as a young guy
you also have to play the role of being
a very sanitized very
public-facing acceptable Don't Rock the
Boat CEO do you ever find conflict
between those two things
yeah absolutely and I try to manage it
in in the right way because you're right
I've got very specific opinions on
things and for example my opinion on the
Lord Hill review I don't feel the need
to run off on YouTube and scream about
it we write a very logical very
formulated letter to the government and
to be fair to them they respond right
and we have we have an ongoing dialogue
I'm not going to move the needle I'm not
going to change anything they probably
don't care what I've got to say but at
least I've done my bit right so
I I'll put my opinion forward in in the
right way in the right place and there
are certain things that I would like to
talk about publicly because
of you know where it's the content I
consume the things that I read and the I
guess my viewpoints under on certain
things
but then again I also see other people
um again without naming names that come
from a completely different industry and
then started talking about politics and
I think just stay in your lane like you
don't know what you're talking about so
I want to make sure that if I ever do
talk about certain things I want to make
sure that it's a really well thought out
opinion I'm complete completely
bulletproof I completely believe in it
and back you know back what I'm talking
about
um but you're right being a CEO of a
of a consumer focused business you know
we wanna we want our product to be
available to everyone and we want lots
of different types of people to buy a
product and I don't want to alienate
anyone because of my personal views and
rightly or wrongly I am intrinsically
linked to the company I founded when I
was a teenager and I think that's just
I think I don't see how that would ever
change and I would love to talk more
publicly about certain things
um
but as I'm sure you're aware of the more
you speak the higher the level of risk
and ultimately the the higher likelihood
you have of alienating certain people at
some point I guess for me it's just at
what point do I make that decision what
do you are you bothered you know could
you go the rest of your life having
private opinions that are kept private
or do you feel uh a bit of discomfort
about the fact that you don't get to
maybe proselytize about stuff that you
do personally genuinely care about but
maybe uh the sort of thing that and
we're not you know we're not talking
about like you're not going to go full
Kanye here like the point is just that
you have viewpoints personally and the
world has uh lost the ability to take
someone's Viewpoint in good faith a lot
of the time and would read into it it's
for instance right so
um the Rogan N word compilation video
from a year ago a couple of years ago
what the world attempted to do there was
say see here is the tip of the iceberg
that proves that Joe is the Unspeakable
bigoted racist misogynistic Heathen that
we've always said he was yeah the way
that this usually works is that there
are vacuums in terms of what you know
about a person there is a small incident
that occurs that the press and people
that don't like them take as being
representative of the entirety of their
being they say this is the tip of the
iceberg below it is this sort of murky
Cesspool of terrible things that they
believe the reason that Joe particularly
was protected was that most people have
seen the entire Iceberg I've listened to
casually you know 500 a thousand even a
normal fan we've listened to hundreds of
hours of this guy and they go look
you're telling me that there's something
lurking down there I've been down there
I know that there's nothing lurking
however
when you have perhaps not thousands and
thousands of hours of content on the
internet when you have more
um vectors of potential attack which is
a 900 000 person company shareholders
stakeholders etc etc
there is more of a risk there yeah
rather than being an individual and I
think
I mean the the best example that I think
I would use that I know we spoke about
earlier would be Jeremy Clarkson
whether you like him or not he made some
comments about Meghan Markle and Prince
Harry a few weeks ago and there was a
lot of conversation about whether or not
his farm show is going to be canceled
now I think the people that wanted the
farm show canceled were probably staring
at Jeremy Clarkson we don't like this
waiting for him to say anything yeah we
we want Jeremy Clark we want to take
Jeremy Clarkson down
and ironically if that show is canceled
he's probably affected the least out of
everyone it's the hundred people that
edit produce develop Farmers the people
that all contribute to the show that are
actually genuinely hurt
and that's the interesting balance of
being a public individual that has an
opinion but also wanting to protect the
wide group of individuals that you work
alongside so it is it is definitely a
difficult line
to balance I'd love to see I'm
interested if you know anyone that does
it particularly well
because
I'm doing it wrong I don't lie there at
night thinking oh God I wish I could
tell everyone about my political views
I'm it's not that big of a deal to me
like I think I said previously I my
intention when starting gymshark was
never to be on social media it it I'm
not massively first
I think the point at which I would get
involved
is if things either got significantly
worse than what they are now or I
genuinely felt I could move the needle
like I made a passing comment a moment
ago of I'll send a letter to the
government with my opinion realistically
it won't move the needle if you said to
me a YouTube video could move the needle
on something that's particularly
important to you you're passionate about
you think would help people now I think
that would probably change my opinion at
the moment I just don't think I've
gotten to that point just generally
personally
what is it that Founders don't know
about the challenges of being a CEO
because this is where do I begin a
journey that I know that you've been on
you've flip-flopped in and out of so the
thing so the thing is with being a
Founder is
it the job which I've never known in any
other job the job literally
flips on its head depending on the scale
of the business and the time so it's
almost like there's peace time there's
war time and then there's scale and the
your approach has to be completely
different and to get a business from
zero to ten million
you essentially have to be very very
dictatorial you tell people what you
want people will tell you this isn't
going to work you ignore comments you
ignore feedback and you do what the hell
you want and you force your business
into success this is my experience right
I'm sure there are other people that
have had different experiences but that
was my personal experience why why do
you need to be dictatorial you have no
time you take high level of risk there
is no there's no time for discussion
generally what you're trying to do
hasn't been done before there's no data
to back up what you're thinking
you need to grow quick okay
I'm like listen we
in that period there were several times
that we risked everything we had
to get to that next level and oftentimes
the risks make no sense because again in
in the and granted the numbers are the
numbers are smaller right but it's a
case of we're doing 250 000 in Revenue
our ambition one day is to do four
million in Revenue you need to risk the
entire house on hopefully getting to one
million what were some of those
inflection points
so for me it was the first events that
we did so we did one event it did well
and what you normally do in a larger
business is you do an event it does well
you sit there you analyze the data you
understand what the ROI would be if you
were to do five more it's like no like
in the early days in that one to ten
that purely entrepreneurial phase that
gut instinct phase is you do have you
have no time to do any of those so we
did our first event it went well we then
sign up to loads of events and then we
went from just doing Birmingham to
Birmingham Germany Australia uh two in
the US was this one you exited body
power yes uh no this is one this one
this wasn't when we exited body power we
did body power and it went really well
so we resigned it rolled it out and then
we kept going and got you and there was
a point I think it was about two years
after that where we'd managed we'd
basically managed to get about a million
pounds in the bank
am I you know being in the West Midlands
and having a company with a million
pound in the banks that I've never heard
of anything like it was the most insane
thing ever in our early 20s
and at that point you've sort of got
something to lose I'm like oh well like
you know if we if we just gave up now
and we just split the money you know mum
and Dad's mortgage is paid I could live
happily yeah maybe not now but it feels
like you could live happily ever after
and then we bet the entire house ongoing
again and stock an event and you do that
again and again and again
and then and this is what I mean so from
naught to 10 you essentially do what the
hell you want 10 to 50 is that bit where
you have an understanding of the fact
that you've actually got something to
lose because for me between 1 and 10
there was nothing to lose 10 to 15 in
Revenue there was certainly something to
lose
but you're filled with this adrenaline
this excitement and this and this
momentum that you're just doing you just
go and at that point you're really
starting to hire people so the the whole
thing of ignoring what everyone says it
just starts to go away because if you're
doing 50 million in Revenue you're doing
a million a week
the likelihood is you probably have a
handful of staff that are helping you
manage that if you just ignore what they
say and do what you want anyway
then going back to what we said earlier
that has that only has a certain period
of time that that can work for and then
what you find is the larger the business
gets the more that you rely on other
people the more or the less that you're
in the detail and then the more that
going off and doing becomes either more
explaining and inspiring as the business
grows so it's I don't I mean very
occasionally but I don't really I would
never sit in front of a sewing machine
anymore
but and I don't sit down and sketch out
products and try and work out exactly
what I want but I need to work out and
this is this is my big challenge now
right trying to scale gym shark into a
truly iconic British brand than a global
brand is how do I
inspire people to create product that
fits in with our overarching strategy
that I'm really proud of and pleased
about that also excites the customer and
he's of a high quality and it's all of
these things and trying to get the right
people in the right right roles and
there's always so many emotions involved
and conversations because other people
have differing views and what I can't do
again is just go it's my way or the
highway because that only has a certain
lifespan to it so the development of
being a small entrepreneurial business
which is a lot of telling to a
large-scale business that works with
people from all around the world deals
with tens and tens of millions of units
of Stark has relatively large Financial
Risk compared to where we were
previously
um and he's trying to become an iconic
brand that is now competing with some of
the biggest brands in the world that
have Bank balances that are 10 100 times
larger than ours that's where it becomes
a fascinating thing because it's more
about it becomes significantly more of
an intellectual and social challenge
than it does this just sort of
adrenaline-filled thing do you miss that
not really
there's times I do but when I actually
sit down and think about it logically I
get to sit in an air-conditioned office
and travel the world now whereas before
when your screen printing and it's
November and it's minus three and the
hose Parts frozen over and you're trying
to clean off the screen
it's easy to say oh and romanticize
those times and say oh I love those
times they were so excited which they
were like my first time going out to
Ohio I've never been to Ohio in my life
and didn't bring any coats or warm
weather on our land in December and it
is freezing and I've never seen snow
like it and those are cool romantic
memories of the growth and whilst I do
enjoy it
it's easy to forget about how hard those
times were and forget about the fact
that there was once a point when I was
stood in La just about to get on a
flight home and I thought that when I
landed home there wouldn't be a business
to go to and I was trying to work out do
I go back to UNI do I go and get another
job do I go and try and start again all
of these different things so
it's easy to romanticize the early days
and it's easy to think oh my job now is
hard and it's cumbersome and it's slower
than what it used to be
um
but I'm an eternal optimist so I would
say I would like to think that it's the
best now it's ever been there will be a
lot of people listening that are
side hustling building a business from
that naught to 10 million stage during
that time
for businesses that are maybe uh less
consumer focused than yours but for many
they'll need to relinquish control they
will start being the person that does
everything and even if you're at one mil
or two mil like you you can't be the
person that does everything you can be
hard charging telling everyone to do it
yeah what is your advice to people that
struggle to delegate that struggle to
relinquish control that struggle to
bring people in underneath them and and
have the faith that they're going to do
it
well I think the first thing I would say
is I think you need to really understand
yourself because for me I I I was
fortunate in the sense that I managed to
work out what I'm good at fairly quickly
and then literally it's quite simple
these are the things I'm good at these
are the things I'm bad at draw a line
between the two Outsource the things
that you're better and I also think that
you don't want don't be precious about
those things those things could be
simple they could be complex but go off
and find people that can do it and
get the best people that you can afford
I think in the early days I think that's
really really important so I mean in the
very early days of gymshark I was well
aware that I didn't really understand
Operations Logistics Finance
and quite frankly people anywhere near
as well as I needed to so brought in a
great CEO and he was Chief exec for I
think five or six years I think six
years Steve was and he managed all of
those things for so your incompetence
was a competitive advantage in that
regard because you felt like you you
didn't have any ownership you already
knew where your weaknesses lay they were
staring you in the face so there was no
problem with relinquishing that control
to someone that was evidently much
better than you edit which is easy to do
if your Ambitions for the business are
larger than your Ambitions for yourself
because the risk what do you mean
if your Ambitions for your business are
larger than your personal Ambitions then
you will put yourself into any role
necessary for the business to succeed if
your Ambitions are larger for yourself
than your business then you will ensure
that you're at the top of the business
at all costs because your personal
ambition is to be Top Dog
the thing the reason that having Steve
come in as CEO was particularly helpful
for me was
it almost had a bit of a flywheel effect
because Steve came in and covered my
weaknesses instantly so from a business
perspective you get a huge tick because
Ben's now not doing things he's not very
good at Ben's only doing things that
he's good at and we've got someone who's
very good Steve at doing the things that
Ben's not very good at so almost like in
the list of things to do you can almost
take everything then
the next thing that that had is it meant
I could not only double down on my
strength so I would move deeper into the
business and I actually ended up doing a
chief of brand job a marketing job a
tech job and a product job so I got
c-suite experience across four different
parts of the business and I have sat in
factories I've you know sat across the
table from people like Google and
Facebook and Shopify worked with
athletes been to pretty much every event
that we ever ran I got to do all of
these things which are very very few
people get the experience and and the
you know the opportunity to do but then
I could also sit with our CFO and our
CEO and learn about finance and Ops and
go to distribution centers and
warehouses and things like that and I
could sit with our CFO and I could say
stupid things that made completely no
sense I could ask stupid questions
knowing that if anything went wrong
there was essentially this safety net
beneath me of both the CFO and the CEO
someone who's less incompetent which is
perfect right because what you want if
you want if you want to improve rapidly
it's a bit like if someone gave you a
test if you're doing your A Levels now
and you can do the test once you'd
probably do relatively well you give the
test a go you get a c but then you get
the test again and you get a c plus and
then I'll give you the same test again
you get a b and then slowly but surely
you get better and better and then we'll
try another test and that's what it felt
like to me I had five years of failure
without without consequence and that is
if you could if you had a magic wand and
you could draw the perfect environment
for learning it would be failure without
consequence because you can literally
just throw yourself at anything that you
want at any given moment
how could have you got any advice for
that sounds fantastic failure without
consequences is amazing for a learning
and iterating process is there any
advice that you would have for how
somebody could integrate this either
into personal professional business life
so that they could
do this more and iterate on that
learning process as an owner or yeah I
think and I think it's worked in any
role right so
if for example you have a you have a an
overarching role that let's say for
example requires 50 creativity and 50
organization and I'm just making up a
job here
and let's say you're the opposite of me
you're a highly conscientious organized
individual that gets everything done
that you need to do but then you're not
maybe creative and you haven't got the
ability to think about what's new and
what's what the next thing is then what
I would implore you to do is Define that
individual and partner yourself very
closely with that individual not only so
that you can learn from them but also so
that they're filling your gaps and your
weaknesses and I also think and I don't
know how this works I don't know if it's
easier for a creative to become
organized than it is someone that's
conscientious to become creative I don't
I would say it's easier for a Creator to
become organized I would say so too the
other way around so maybe I'm quite
lucky from that perspective
um but equally some of the best business
people I've met are the opposite of me
they're not that creative they're just
highly driven organized bold good at
taking risks that's because if you had a
business filled with you you would have
fantastic ideas but nothing would get
done correct correct I look at um video
guidance been to my house in Austin and
I live with Zach back and he couldn't be
more different to me in terms of his
sort of psychological personality makeup
he plays five different instruments he's
like super super creative girlfriend and
artist etc etc and you can see a
physical manifestation of our two
personalities when you walk into each of
our Studios that back into each other so
you go into mine and everything is neat
and tidy I press three buttons and all
of the lights come on it's very very
dialed I walk into his there's been a
sock sellotape to his wall from the
first day that he moved in I have no
idea why it's there neither does he
they'll be like banana peels around the
play It's like a like a Tom and Jerry
cartoon so I would probably be closer to
that I think so albeit I've had to try
myself to
be more organized through whether it's
working with great people whether it's
as stupid as using the right
applications and things like that and
trying to walk and organize myself
what's the biggest risk that you've
taken
with gymshark
over its entire lifespan do you think
um
I think I think it all varies isn't it
so the
the first events that we ever did
because we risked everything on the
events being successful and if the
events weren't successful then we would
have run out of money so that that's
without a doubt one I mean personally
leaving like I was the first person in
my family to ever go to university I
didn't finish University but that whole
thing of calling calling at my mom and
dad and going you know this thing I've
worked really really hard for I'm now
going to leave it that that was a
personal risk albeit not a Financial
Risk
um
so and we've done we've had plenty of
financial risks ten they tended to be
earlier on in the process
um
those would be the main ones again
this is going to sound really bad but
the Financial Risk is never really
frightened me too much
and the reason for that is is when I was
when I was a young kid I did
um the first ever
I guess experience of work for me was
working on work experience for my
Grandad my Grandad lines furnaces in the
Midlands so brick ceramic fiber laboring
job I basically just did labor labor for
him
and he would tell me and he's a one-man
band it's it's not by no means a huge
business
um but he loves he loves what he does
right and he would tell me about how he
risked everything he had on a job where
he was basically building a furnace that
was due to be sent out to Germany and
for whatever reason there was this point
in the process where it could have gone
horrifically wrong and he would tell me
from the age of
I don't know 12 13 14 very young anyway
about he would sit there and think
am I going to have a roof to put over
the my mom her sister my Nan's head
and when you've been when that's been
drilled into you from a young child that
my family have taken those risks and
that level of risk and I spent a lot of
time with my grandparents growing up
because my mum work nights in the NHS
that my dad would often work away and
things like that
the the risk that I then take on aren't
that big so the take a million quid at
22 years old on events
when worst case I can go back to
University and get another job of pizza
it it never felt
frightening in a way it was more
exciting do you think that that's
because of your optimistic mindset yes
and high level for risk tolerance
I think I get I get I really enjoy
things like that like risks like that
really excite me that's something that
I'm trying to get better at um taking
risks and my disposition is very very uh
conservative iterate very slowly it's
meant that I've basically made zero
mistakes ever when it comes to business
but the fact that I've made zero
mistakes is probably an indication that
I should have taken more risk on yeah
um
that's something again British culture I
think I would say very much discourages
risk yeah overall very very just softly
softly slowly slowly like you know let
me limit your uh potential upside but
also massively limit your downside as
much as you can
we've spoken a lot about sort of
business the operations of business but
fundamentally what you are doing is
encouraging Fitness in the world right
like it's facilitating people uh feeling
better about their bodies thinking about
the way that they train the way that
they show up not only just the physical
but now moving into the mental as well
what is different
about what the world needs from Fitness
content now compared to when you started
very so I think
and I'm speaking about the content I
consumed right so I was a kid I was
skinny and I just wanted to build muscle
that was it like I'm not gonna
sit here and go on like I had some
greater goals around Fitness personally
I wanted to be ripped muscular pretty
much like every other 18 year old guy
that was probably around her in that era
I was inspired by Greg Plitt I was
inspired by ziz
that that that was my like Rob Riches
people like that like not necessarily
the big bodybuilders but the people that
were ripped and shredded and that that
was my personal ambition and it felt
like that that was
very much definitely the bodybuilding
industry was definitely around that
because even if you think if we think if
I think back to when I first got into
fitness
the big bodybuilders didn't really get
into social media they were almost like
they almost looked down their nose a
little bit at that new era of people
that were coming up
um so when I think back to that era and
then you have the mat overseas and the
Chris Lovato this is where Jim started
to come along a few years later when I
think of that era of people versus now
it's interesting because it feels like
the mental element has come a lot more
into it and I when I talk about the
mental element
I feel like people talk about mental
health all the time and I do think it's
important but it's
it's so much more about
it's almost like maximizing your
potential
holistically rather than you know having
a good mental health and good physical
health I would say it's like it feels
slightly harder
now and more direct than what it was and
it also feels a little bit to me like
male Mental Health
seems to be being talked about a hell of
a lot more than what it was previously
um
I don't know how to put this in a more
masculine way
um how do you mean
I think when you think about people like
Andrew huberman and the things that he
talks about
and the way that it feels a bit like
people are men are being encouraged to
be more manly for lack of a better term
and I don't see that as a negative by
the way I think I think there's a
massive massive positive whereas I'm not
saying that there was an opposite before
but I just felt like that thing didn't
exist and I think that it's interesting
because over the years before it was how
many bicep curls do I need to do a week
to have big arms it's almost like
everyone knows that now and if you want
if if you don't know that if you're a
young 16 year old kid you're in the gym
you've worked out within a week on
YouTube yeah so then people are now
going a lot deeper in this in in terms
of like Okay so
how how do I become a better man in
general rather than just how do I have
bigger muscles how do I show up in the
world yeah yeah I think that's a really
nice way to frame it that previously
you know when we were starting training
it was uh The misc Forum on
bodybuilding.com spent a lot of time
there abused on there as well I bet you
did uh like Christian Thibodeau T Nation
like all of this like that kind of world
no one knew what macros were no one knew
if blueberry extract was actually going
to be the secret to your muscle gains
then it was very bro sciency and it was
like if you don't have a protein shape
within 30 minutes to finish at the gym
you will lose all of your gains and you
need to have your creatine every 30
minutes and you've got your pre-workout
your intra workout your pro and it was
just like to the point where I remember
shoving hyperbolic Mass down my throat
in a bid to somehow gain weight whereas
now that whole world just seems to have
it just completely has changed and
correct and weirdly enough I mean
certainly in the areas that I spend time
on on social media now it's far more
around
a genuinely good diet a good organic
diet that is balanced with a balanced
level of Fitness that probably
incorporates some weight training but
also in court to level incorporates the
level of cardio and it feels like a more
balanced approach to Fitness now I would
agree so when we're talking about
um integrating men masculinity and how
it's not just about turning up and
looking good it's not just about talking
about mental health and I had a problem
for ages for the people that are
listening from the US there was a
campaign in the UK called it's okay to
talk right and this was trying to
encourage men to open up about Mental
Health
and I always felt icky about it I always
just it didn't resonate with me I
thought
I'm very passionate about mental health
suffered with bouts of depression
throughout all of my twenties
um was the person that needed to be
spoken to by this and yet it takes you
know like a Canadian psychologist or a
Stanford Professor or like a bald MMA
commentator or a neuroscientist that's
into meditation to start talking to me
in a way that made me genuinely consider
my mental health what I've reflected on
the reason I didn't like it's okay to
talk is well [__] no surprise like
obviously it's okay to talk like what's
the next step like give me something
that I can actually use here and the
other side of it and this I learned from
Adam Lane Smith great psychotherapist he
said that male depression gets treated
like female depression men are made to
feel loved and accepted when they want
to feel capable and powerful and the
problem that we had there was that you
were treating male depression and male
mental health like female depression
yeah
it's interesting as well me and me and
I'll talk about this quite a lot as well
in the sense that
if I think of growing up that's why I
had a great upbringing right I remember
there was a few years ago someone struck
a camera in front of me on gymshark's
come up and said tell me about your
terrible upbringing and how difficult it
had been and everyone that said no and I
was like I'm not doing this because I
had a brilliant upbringing I've got
great parents great grandparents and
when I think to the way my mom raised me
in a very caring loving thoughtful way
and then I think about the lessons that
my dad taught me there's two things that
really stand out
it's going to sound really
basic once I rode my bike over my
neighbor's lawn and he grabbed me around
the Scruff of the neck and he said you
respect other people's property you
never do that again you go and apologize
and it was very much tough love and that
that for me was the the male role model
would be tough be strong be respectful
and there was another there's another
one and I remember when I was re I'd
done something wrong and I was really
I'd completely [__] up and I was so
upset and my mom wasn't there for
whatever reason
and I was expecting my dad to sort of
come and go you know but everything's
going to be all right and he just sat
there and he went what you gonna do
about it
and that feeling of
then you have to be strong you have to
take control of the situations and you
have to take control and he always told
me he said you know you have to be
mentally strong you have to be mentally
strong it was something that was drilled
into me from a young age
but that thing of
I don't want to be cuddled
I want I just want the truth and I want
to know what I've got to do I work out
on my own head how I get there but I
just and that I think that speaks back
to that thing that you've just said of
it's it feels like it's things have to
be much more tangible what are you going
to do about it rather than I don't want
someone personally and maybe I'm
Different to others I don't want someone
just to sit there and straight my ego
and tell me that everything's gonna be
okay and I'm okay the way I am because I
think that over a prolonged period of
time
can definitely lead to entitlement I
think it can lead to softness and
weakness and I don't think it's the
right thing in the long term certainly
not for me it's one of the problems that
you have between male and female
communication all of the guys that are
in relationships will know that
sometimes they're having a conversation
with their misses and they are trying to
offer up Solutions
which every time that they offer up a
potential solution infuriates the
conversation more yeah and this is
because men are speaking to women in the
way that they would want to be spoken to
which is find me a solution on average
there are feminine men and there are
masculine women
but
on average it's what's the solution how
can we move forward about this and there
is a large chunk of girls who want to be
heard just look here the things that I'm
saying maybe we can talk about the the
solutions a little bit further down the
line but for now I just want to be able
to like make me feel like you you
understand and you hear what I'm saying
yeah and you're there laying out a
tactical operational plan of what it is
so I think that that's
an interesting Arc that we're talking
about here going from what's the first
level of of like you know male
development which maybe came about
perhaps due to men starting to feel like
they uh were less required you know 2000
and like six to 2012 you are more
visible online
um just generally as a man people are
starting to scrutinize the way that you
look you're able to compare yourself to
people but wasn't this the point where
obesity obesities became a thing in the
early 2000s where everyone sort of said
I think it was it was at the point where
the us became it was something like 40
or 50 obese and then I'd never heard the
term obese until the early 2000s and it
might just be an age thing then all of a
sudden obesity became a thing and that's
when I remember it being the school they
took all the chocolate bars away and
then started putting in I don't know
broccoli or something else so all of a
sudden Health became it was the Jamie
Oliver era I remember really being
really annoyed because they got rid of
the dairy milks at our school [__] Jamie
Oliver I can't believe it but you know
it it I think that's where it started
for me Health definitely became a thing
and I think you're right all of a sudden
postings pictures on social media
comparing yourself to people that are
thousand miles away yeah all of these
things definitely would applied into
that foreign so we roll the clock
forward and people have integrated the
fact that physical fitness is something
that's important mental health everybody
always knew was in there but we then
needed strategies to be able to move
forward
a lot of your audience gymshark
especially is particularly unique in
that it's split it kind of came up
um focused very heavily on male
influences and now I would guess you
probably sell more women to her women's
work yeah right so you have this kind of
odd flip but you have been uh on the
front lines of observing male identity
masculinity and its challenges
what do you think about masculinity in
2023 and the challenges that young men
are facing oh god
um
well I definitely think that cuddle the
cuddle culture certainly isn't helping
from a male perspective I think
I think we're starting to see more good
male role models in What fields like the
last three or four months like recently
it feels like there's more great male
role models that have sort of that have
popped up which I think is helpful
I think I think I saw something that you
said previously around point to me point
point me towards a great male role model
whereas now I can think of at least
three or four whereas previously I
definitely couldn't
I think that's that's helpful and if I
think to male role models previously
especially For Me growing up other than
other than footballers
as a Brit I genuinely can't think of any
um
what does it say that men need those
Role Models now
I think everyone needs a role model I
think it's important to have role models
and I think you pick different people
for different things I don't think
there's one archetypical male that
exists somewhere that does everything
that you know has great uh muscle mass
really intelligent yeah all these sorts
of things and that's what personally
I'll do like I'll have people that
inspire me from a fitness perspective
from an intellectual perspective and so
on so I think having that helps
um
I think it's tough I think
because
personally for me I'm as inspired by
someone's personal life particularly now
as their professional life like I put a
Blog in front of me who's a billionaire
it's it's cool and everything but
you'd rather have one percent of their
wealth with a wonderful family life and
you you know have a great time with your
family you love your job you
challenge yourself intellectually that
full package for me is significantly
more important than than just a a
numerical Financial figure
but I think that may be I think men
might also skew that way the older they
get and as their life circumstances
change in the same way that mine have
because if you said that to 18 year old
Ben give me the billions oh yeah I think
it would have taken every time so many
of the
um
trends that we're seeing I think at the
moment can just be explained by cohorts
of guys and girls arriving and then
phasing out into new areas of their life
so you could say that so many people
would and this is stupid right because
everybody is born each day there is
someone born but they congeal together
into a culture that moves as a group and
then there is another bubble behind can
you imagine why that's definitely that I
think you and I grew up in different
parts of the UK and have been on very
different Journeys but I think if we
were to write down every year since 2006
I'm sure we probably have had similar
views and experiences correct we've
tracked a lot of it we looked up to the
same people we read the same stuff we
got exposed to the same stuff followed
each other on Facebook
um
so we have this sort of bubble that's
going on and then a particular
Trend a particular influence occurs that
group finds identity with it and then
phases out of it and that falls away and
evaporates so you know Andrew Tate just
got out of prison yesterday or this
morning or whatever
um he has a particular cohort of young
guys that look up to him
um but that cohort over time is going to
fall away they will maybe he'll grow
with them maybe they'll find that he's
even more compelling as they grow up or
maybe not but for us and our age and who
it was that we grew up with it very much
was very physique focused very much
about how lean you were how big you were
it was that Christian Guzman and Matt
August and like Jeff side and all that
and then that fell away and
for us what we needed I think and for a
lot of the guys that are listening
because they're all the same age
we realized that we'd focused Skin Deep
for so long
and maybe we'd got really good at
focusing skin deep and we're in really
good condition and we're wearing loads
of like cool clothes or whatever
but that there was it was a little
Hollow perhaps inside of that and that
we needed something else it's like okay
I've developed the fitness side of me
yeah you know what yeah give me some
[__] substance and I think that that
cohort if you were to pick the
archetypal like Peterson Rogan Harris
Shapiro Alanda botton fanboy
um there is a huge cohort that would
have come out of like the misc
bodybuilding forums oh yeah that would
have come out of like gym culture and
bro culture thinking this is if only I
had the six-pack of Greg Plitt that will
fix all of my problems
I've got myself to a stage where I'm
happy with my body and [__] I still have
problems it's is it was it the Jim
Carrey quote that goes something like I
hope you all get to achieve your dreams
so that you can realize
that maybe it's not so great or it's
words of that effect isn't it but I feel
like it's very similar from a physique
perspective as maybe it is a financial
perspective I think people are willing
to snap their back to get to a certain
Financial figure in search of happiness
I feel like I can speak from personal
experience that whilst it does help in
many many different ways you will not
find happiness purely through financial
the you know the pursuit of financial
gains what are you worth do you know
what you're worth I try to think I don't
know I do not want to know nor think and
I think why don't you want to know
because it's just all numbers on a
screen it doesn't it doesn't
so much of my wealth is tied up in
gymshark which has a fluctuating value
that change on the day if I was to
assign any form of
self-worth or spend too much time
considering it that my mood would
fluctuate more than the weather
and I think that that's something for me
that I
I would I'd never ever think about that
and I swear to God that is the last
thing I think about at all
um
but again I think maybe that is an age
thing a situation thing being married
kids all these sorts of things
I've got great Ambitions for the
business and I want the business to be
at a certain level you know and that a
spit out of that is to be worth a
certain level and that excites me but
it's certainly not why I go to work
every day
one of the other things that has
happened over the last 10 years
particularly has been the body
positivity movement
when gymshark first came around those
leggings that had the line under the ass
crack at the bottom that like
accentuated bums and so on and so forth
um the women and their uh challenges in
terms of roles I think I'm terminally
online I spend all of my time thinking
about human nature and how it relates to
the world around us we're talking a lot
about sort of masculinity in men's
problems I flew out to Qatar to have a
debate about this only two weeks ago if
I was to like pick a trend at the moment
that I think in five years time is going
to become the new existential crisis I
think it's girls I think that we have
insane rates well we do we know that we
do the peer research just came out about
this unbelievable rate it's like one in
two to like 60 of girls in their teens
have serious depression on mental health
problems one in two right it's
unbelievable so I think that that's
coming down the pike I think that it's
something that we need to be concerned
about but given the fact that you've
seen
a lot of changes uh and one of them has
been the body positivity movement
you have wife that was involved heavily
in the fitness world and was doing the
influence stuff have you got a viewpoint
on that have you got a viewpoint on the
challenges that women have faced and and
uh yeah the so I think the interesting
thing with that is insurance I think
there's a point where our conversations
would not I think we pushed it too far
at points this is the thing with with
running a company
you're running a company here there's
this thread of trend of conversation and
you need to straddle the line between
the trend and the conversation and then
the consistency of where you want the
company to go and there would definitely
point to a wee straight I think too far
towards that body positivity
conversation because I think it got
hijacked and went too far
now the one thing I would say is I was a
skinny kid who wanted to build muscle
and we at gymshark don't believe that a
skinny male in the UK that wants to
build muscle we don't believe that his
ambition and his desire to go to the gym
is any better than an American girl that
wants to lose weight right you're in the
gym because you want to improve and
everyone wants to develop whether it is
muscle building you want to run a faster
5K you want to deadlift 300 kilos you
want to lose I don't know 30 pounds of
fat 50 pounds of fat whatever it is we
don't tier goals we say that everyone's
goal is equal and again I think that's
become more relevant to me because I
wouldn't have said that 10 years ago
it was it was six pack six pack abs or
bust was the ambition for me whereas now
it's very very different so I think that
from that point of view that that's what
I where I think the message needs to be
the bit where I start to get concerned
is when people start to promote
unhealthy physiques and that's not to
say that different physique shouldn't be
shown but to promote an unhealthy
physique and for me to suggest that that
unhealthy physique is somewhat right
beneficial
for an individual that's what concerns
me slightly and this is on both sides of
the fence right you can look at the guy
that walks around you can look at the
guy that walks around at five percent
body fat and say that this is a a
well-balanced weight meanwhile
testosterone's in the toilet hasn't had
an erection in six months irritable some
of the people that I know who have some
of the most incredible physiques you've
ever seen have the worst relationship
with their body mentally
and you'll know that as well as I do
people don't step on stage in some of
these huge competitions and and some of
them are absolutely fine some of them
have deep rooted mental issues which is
why they're putting their body through
such trauma and I think most of those
people that are smart realize that they
can only do that a certain amount of
times before the risk becomes too high
so you're right it's not just people
that are overweight it's people that are
literally bulking up beyond all doubt
and then dieting themselves on the verge
of starvation in order to win a
competition and there's you're right
there's extremes at both ends but I
think the thing that concerns me is just
the fact that I don't think we should be
promoting the Extremes in a way that
suggests that they're healthy I think
there are certain elements where you can
understand admire whatever you want to
call it the extreme so if I'm massively
inspired by if I see a picture of Dorian
Yates another guy from Birmingham Phil
he's just because of the accent it's not
the photo it's the accent but even close
the table like Ryan Terry yep seen him
in pictures he's cool seeing him in real
life it is insane like I look at him
it's crazy it's his
mental fortitude to get himself into
that position is absolutely incredible
where I'd start to worry is if he got
himself into that condition and remain
there for a prolonged period of time
like I think that that has to be of
concern just in the same way that if a
friend or family member of mine was to
get quite overweight
I wouldn't sit there and say that that's
okay and it doesn't mean I wouldn't care
for them or love them any any less but I
would say listen I I would say it's
beneficial for your long-term Health if
you were to get into decent physical
condition I don't think everyone needs
six-pack abs everyone doesn't need to be
able to the dead of 300 kilos
but moving being in the gym and having a
certain level of Fitness I think is only
helpful for everyone
you have recently had twins yes how old
are they now they are 14 weeks today
right they're fresh they're fresh out of
the oven
I remember listening to a podcast that
you did a little while ago where you
were reflecting on a conversation that
you had with your ea uh and she said
something to the effect of you're not
going to be able to do this when you
have kids uh and you decide
to deal with it when it's in front of me
you don't need to worry about that
um
given that you are now at the coal face
what have been the lessons
introspections changes that you've
noticed over the last 14 weeks well
first and foremost I I was wrong so Zoe
was right she was saying you're not you
can't continue to work either if it was
in this right or in this way I think it
was more in this way when you have kids
and and the reason was is
very obviously my life and gymshark just
blended into one it was a seven day a
week job I'd sit there and I'd work on a
Saturday on a Sunday on a Monday it
would be fairly loose and free and open
I'd just work all the time cool and I
love my job and I continue to do so so
I wasn't sat there thinking oh God I'm
annoyed that I'm working on a Sunday I
thoroughly enjoyed it and the fact that
I would travel a lot and I'd be away for
lots of weekends and things like this
whereas now all of a sudden having kids
I want to be at home on the weekends but
the work is still there so it's gotten a
lot more intense for me in the sense
that again we just did a trip out
um we did it we did a trip to Colorado a
few months ago and what we'd normally do
is fly out on a Saturday look around on
the Sunday maybe go out to Breckenridge
or somewhere like that relax work Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday fly
home Friday making a leisurely Journey
back from Heathrow on a Saturday whereas
now it's fly out Monday work Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday fly home Thursday
lunchtime land home Friday walk through
the front door and have a child thrown
at me sort of thing so it's very very
different and like it I would say I've
become significantly more purposeful in
my time and and that's in every every
facet of my life right so if I'm at work
I'm at work and if I'm at home I'm at
home and previously I'd be tapping away
a lot more on my phone I've started to
like turn my phone off on Sunday
afternoons I'm going to try and do that
potentially for a whole day on Sunday
just so that I'm present and with them
um the travel more present when I'm at
home and at work and I think things like
that it certainly made me think and
they're still very young right they're
newborn at the moment so they're not
necessarily notice and if I'm on my
phone but I'm very aware of the fact
that within a few months I don't want my
kids to have a dad that was just messing
around on his phone all the time and
there's an interesting Insight that I
learned there again from Adam Lane Smith
which is
a lot of the time parents are
considerate in becoming increasingly
more aware of their kids using devices
right do you want your child to have to
be only distracted by YouTube for kids
or whatever one of the things a lot of
parents don't consider is the fact that
if they hear that Ding and the ding
causes mum or Dad to look at the phone
the child's relationship to the phone
and the relative amount of attention
that the parents have with them is
something that is very very quickly
forgotten I think and you know again
don't have kids can't wait to be a dad
but when I do
my uh Grand idea of how I'm going to
have a relationship with technology may
get thrown out of the [__] window
however I think that there is like a
really really good argument to be made
that if you're in the room with your kid
the phone shouldn't be in there as well
if you want to use a device
step outside of the room because we just
do not know what second order
consequences that are of your child
playing second or third string to
something that's in your hand
yeah and these are all the things that
I've now started to think about that I
would previously never have thought
about
and even stupid things like the job is
still busy my travel is certainly
reduced
we like renovating a farm in the middle
of nowhere where we want to be able to
have the kids grow up we want to be able
to grow all our own food and like live a
proper like Branch life and just little
things like that and it's it's so
different to the way that I grew up and
it might be a combination of me getting
older being in the position I'm in I
think it's just a position that we are
in in the world as well I think with
everything that's gone on politically
globally with Kobe and everything I
think the amount of people that have
just gone thought this I just want to be
self-sufficient and do my own thing to a
degree I think is
I think has increased dramatically
so
yeah I think it's definitely changed my
perspective on lots of things and a lot
of people were saying
I know Noah was asking me this he was he
was interested to watch how my
relationship with work changed
and
I'm arguably even more hell-bent on
making this a success and working
incredibly hard at work because
I want my kids to look at me and think
that I want to be the role I want to be
a true role model Ryan Terry said the
same thing and I want to work hard I
want to be successful and I want them to
see that
and I want to do it in the right way
whereas I think some people thought oh
is Ben just being honest I don't have to
work I could retire and live on that
farm and Mr 70 Ever After
but is that the sort of dad that I want
my kids to see because that's not real
life and I want them to see that you
have to work hard in order to you know
in order to get what you want from life
and I think it's the right thing that
for me and that's what I want them to do
and I want them to find a job that they
love they don't need to be millionaires
they don't need to earn loads of money
that in no way bothers me in the
slightest but
for them to grow up seeing their dad
doing something he loves but also having
a good time with them I think is really
exciting to me and that's what I want
them to do as they grow up
you have the opportunity to give your
kids materially opportunities that you
didn't have as a kid
the lack of opportunities that you had
the exposure to your uncle or Grandad
that was making stoves and risking it
all on a 100 Grand stove or whatever
that was shipping to Germany has formed
you into a person not only that you're
proud of but one that has objectively
been able to become quite successful
yeah how do you consider marrying the
difference between giving your kids the
opportunity that you have materially
whilst putting them through the
challenges that you know were formative
and important for you to get to where
you are now again that's what I'm
thinking about a lot and so me and Robin
have spoken so they're definitely not
going to private school so that's
something that's important to me and I'm
I'm the sort of person that reads into
this right I read all the papers there
is a dramatically higher likelihood they
will be quote unquote successful if they
go to private school then if they go to
I don't know what you call it a normal
school
they're not going to go to private
school I mean if you speak to Robin she
wants to homeschool them I'm I'm not
quite on that boat yet I'm happy just I
think that's an American an American
Canadian influence heavily it's very
rare over here in the UK yeah America
Canada tells me that that movement is
growing rapidly but I haven't looked
into that yet
um for me I think it's important to go
to a normal school I think listen
they're going to grow up in a nice house
with nice things and they're going to be
able to have connections to cool people
and great people in a way but I think
for me it's about just bringing them up
in the right way and the way that my
parents did in the way that my
grandparents did it was really important
to me that
they were born and they would have the
opportunity to spend time with my
grandparents their great-grandparents
which you know touchwood at the moment
they can that's really important to me
because they have a completely different
viewpoint on life so similar to pretty
much I guess every kid in the UK
both of my all of my great-grandparents
on the male side all fought in the War
right my grandparents so I spent a lot
of time with growing up would tell me
stories about what it was like growing
up when they grew up my nan would talk
to me about how in her garden they would
grow one vegetable next door they would
grow another and they would all share at
the end of the week because that was the
way that it worked when they were
rationing my other grandfather who I
worked closely would tell me about when
his dad came back from War and the
difficulties in the family and the
family split up because of
different issues he came back with and
I felt fortunate to spend so much time
with my grandparents growing up because
I didn't I don't think I had a
conventional upbringing of someone that
was born in 1992. I had this weird mix
of someone that was born in 1992 but
then also a 1960s style upbringing
because I spent so much time with my
grandparents as well and they that might
account for the tradition yes which I
think it does they taught me so much and
because of the amount of time that I
spent with them
so I think for me to somehow instill
those values and beliefs in my kid is
really really important to me
um how I do that I don't know because
some things you just have to learn
yourself and one of the things that I
learned myself that I that other people
couldn't
for whatever reason teach me was I had
this feeling of I just can't wait to get
out of get out of the UK I can't wait to
get out of England I want to go
somewhere else in Australia I want to be
in the US I want to see the world and
everywhere is going to be so much better
than this because England is this and
it's that and it's all these things and
I'm really lucky right I've traveled
into more countries than I could ever
imagine I've spent lots and lots of time
across loads of different states in the
United in the US in Canada across Asia
all these different places
and I can't help but feel the more I
travel
I feel more and more lucky to have been
born in the UK and if you just said that
to 16 17 18 year old Ben he would have
not believed you in a million years
but I'm again we had the opportunity to
raise our kid anywhere in the world
and I chose here
because I think it's such an amazingly
brilliant place to raise a kid and
you're right there's this way you want
to call it crabs in a bucket syndrome
they're in negatives the media can be a
bit of a pain in the ass and we've had
more prime ministers in the last six
months than probably most I've had in
the last six years all these different
things but when I look at it
the net positives of being here are so
great what are they net positives have
been in the UK people forget that if you
want to start a business business in the
UK especially an e-commerce business one
we speak English which is great it's
helpful for communicating with the
Western world
two you can ship things to Europe in 24
hours pretty much 70 million people in
the UK within 20 uh like within 24 hours
so you've got the whole of Europe and
the UK and your doorstep
a lot of that is down to the fact that
there's so many countries in Europe each
one have it has its own sort of
operational setup whether it's DVD Royal
Mail or these different companies
um so the operational supply chain of
Europe is incredible you can ship to the
east coast of the United States in 24 48
hours I know people that started very
similar businesses to gymshark at a very
similar time in Australia and I think
they were incredibly talented and I
think some part of the reason that we
we grew significantly more quickly than
they did
not completely down to this is because
we're in the UK and we could ship to all
of these different countries
significantly more quickly and they were
shipping from places like Mel but it was
taking them three weeks to get to the US
and Europe and places like that beyond
the advantages specifically in the UK of
e-commerce companies cultural advantages
culturally we punch way above our way
the amount of British actors
uh presenters and things like that that
you see in the US in the UK in the
Australia and places like that it's
incredible
um
I think we've got an amazing education
system
I think albeit we've got a turbulent and
mental government
it's way better than 99 of other
countries
and I know people moan and I know
they're a mistake and this is the other
thing as well and this this is what
frustrates me with a lot of people is
you meet so many people especially in
the UK and the US that go and I don't
think he's great right Biden made the
stupid mistake surprise surprise he's an
old bloke right
um really soon I made this stupid
mistake and I'm like
yeah but anyone that's worked in any
business or in any large-scale
organization has made a million mistakes
it's really [__] hard you couldn't do
a better job and I think I think we just
need to take stock of that for that for
the most part we have it really really
good and do we have the most competent
people
in our government that we could possibly
have no but
where does where where does and I think
your alternative is if you will go if
you were to go purely uncommon
competency you'd probably end up
significantly closer to a China or
somewhere like that correct
correct and I always say to people you
could go and live in China and I've
never met anyone that says yes I'd love
to do that so I think I think the
benefits from an economic perspective of
the UK in a country that punches above
its weight that has great connections
into the work to the entire of the West
that has great social influence across
the world are you a safe country are you
yeah that's not nothing as well
um a lot of the concerns at the moment
do come
in America a lot of my friends the
reason you've got Waldorf schools have
you heard of those okay so there's a
bunch of um
alternative semi-auternative
schooling systems
um
very based around being outdoors
um teaching teaching kids like to you
know like hunt and dress animals and
stuff very much Back to Basics there but
like let's be real one of the reasons is
that they're very concerned about some
of the ideologies that are being pushed
to kids in schools correct yes that for
me
looking at the UK for all that the U.S
coughs and we catch a cold it is
100th of the amount of psychological
Contagion mimetic the whole shitery that
goes on in the US it's frightening is
that something that you have highly
considered 100 and I think
I think maybe you see this more being in
the US and for you living in the US and
for me spending a decent amount of time
in the US I think you see more of that
now if you were to again this is where
my I guess my optimism comes out if you
zoom out what generally happens it'll be
like this but it will jet like the s p
it will generally Trend up and the US
will get better and better and I'm a
massive long-term believer in the United
States I think it is an amazing Place
full of amazing people
I'm just thinking for the next 50 years
how much of that do I want to take
whereas in the UK they go to a local
school it's not hunting but they'll do
forestry they have the little place in
the in the local village where they get
to grow their own they'll grow their own
food they learn good skills they'll do
well enough and they'll have decent
enough education on English and maths
and things like that they can pursue
what they want to creatively
I think it's great and I think
I think that listen there's so many
things that are exciting about the UK
um and I think we've got it really
really good I really do and I think
there's so many people in the UK and in
the US for that matter that just
constantly focus on the negatives
um
and like I said I'm but I'm a I'm more
of an optimist and I think that the the
long-term
effect will be a net positive as well I
think so too
right I do have concerns over those
exact things and I do think about them
and maybe it's different for me because
I'm in a privileged position where I can
just choose to not allow my child to be
involved in certain things that I don't
want them to if you live in a place and
that school provides that and you're not
happy with it and you're stuck with it
maybe my opinion would be slightly
different that's a concern for a lot of
people that they they can't rip their
kids out of
a situation where they don't agree with
the particular ideology the particular
cultural milieu that's going on but I
mean you've said that you've done a lot
of the research I was talking to uh Ryan
about this yesterday and he's I think
his two-year-old is at private school at
the moment and at this school there's
kids turning up in helicopters there's
kids turning up on in Bentley's uh and
you know he's I think even more working
class as working class correct yeah yeah
he's absolutely scum
um and he Ryan Terry by the way tells
everyone he was a plumber
I think the lads were out at a shoot in
Airbnb in LA and the toilet broke
and he didn't know how to fix it so I
think we should also at some point dig
in to understand how good a plumber is
oh you think that this is I think even
though he was I'm not debating whether
or not he was a plumber I just think
you're right I think he was a ship
plumber so I think Ryan I'm afraid that
you need to come through and fix some
pipes for us in order to prove that your
backstory is not completely just
confabulated
he's got this problem at the moment and
I mentioned it to him yesterday and I
may as well tell it to you too
um especially given that you've got
twins which is pretty interesting are
they identical twins yeah wow
monozygotic twins need to introduce you
to Robert Plowman so he's the number one
behavioral geneticist on the planet
every pair of twins born in the UK
between 1991 and 1994 were enrolled into
this study and they ended up holding on
to I think around about 50 to 60 000
pairs yeah of twins and he has teased
apart the differences between nature and
nurture more than anybody right I'd be
interested in that because I haven't got
into the detail of it but there's visit
even though you've got the same DNA
there's
environmental factors that cause the DNA
to basically
I don't know what you want to call it
this is where you sort of get to the
edge of my competency but they've shown
in different ways don't they and I'm
interested to know what how that works
so the epigenetic changes how does the
environment influence the genes to be
honest ploman doesn't really get into
that much and for me
like epigenetics
vibrational frequencies Quantum astral
route all that stuff is a little bit
like the god of the gaps argument to me
it's like a place where we don't quite
understand as far as I can tell just
what's going on and people use it as a a
wedge in which they can drive basically
wishful thinking and desires so
when it comes to uh kids and
um schools overall when you account for
everything genetics socioeconomic status
all the rest of it taking a kid out of
one school and putting them into another
has less than five percent of a
difference in their academic outcomes
the biggest influence it seems like that
you have in the nurture side of Nature
and nurture is not you it's not your
wife it's the parents of the kids that
your kids hang around with it's the kids
that your kids hang around with and it's
the
coaches the school teachers which is
ruthless for parents to find out that
they are not the biggest influence on
their child's life like the biggest
determinant of your future wealth level
is not that of your parents it's the
average of the postcode that you grow up
in why what's because who you exposed to
who are the people that you take your
values and your virtues from now
again this is on average if you had a
family which was incredibly insular
um you know yours multi-generational
four generations of of people
interacting with each other you spent a
lot of time with that you're going to
supplement what typically would have
happened socially outside of the home
like still outside of the home but
within one family structure right
um but my point being that
the number one piece of advice that I
would give to parents that want to raise
kids with values work ethic all the rest
of it that they want to have
carefully that the kids that your kids
spend time with carefully that the
parents of the kids that your kids spend
time with carefully about the coaches of
the sports teams the teachers at the
schools
um that is some of the longest leverage
that you can find if you want to have
kids that hold those sorts of values
that that have the upbringing and the
principles that you want them to have
those are the real long levers I think
I have no idea
really important man really really
important Robin will see that and she'll
think I definitely want a home home
school the boys now well homeschooling's
not nothing as well like you know I'm
speaking as an only child here that um
under socializing kids puts them in
advantages in some regards because you
have massive amounts of self-sufficiency
uh Total Comfort with working in
isolation with being in isolation with
taking risks says the guy that moved out
to America at 33 to like just try and
speak to people on the internet
but the problem is that you need to
really work hard to offset the um lack
of ability in terms of socialization
that would accumulate over six hours a
day in school around other kids being
exposed to other cultures here is
someone from a Muslim background here is
someone that's Jewish here is someone
that's from a wealthy family here is
someone that's from a poor family here's
somebody that's misbehaved so here's
somebody that's a bully here's some all
of those different iterations I think my
concern I love the idea of homeschooling
but my concern is how less worldly and
Street Smart do you make your kids it's
a yeah what's the consequence it's kind
of a cuddling again in a regard now a
solution for this
another thing which is happening a lot
in LA in America at the moment but
especially in Austin people are making
homesteads where
10 families of my rich friends will find
100 acres somewhere near Austin set up
with a bunch of kids so you'll maybe
have you know 10 15 kids and they'll
home school it's not far off just a
school yeah now if it's just you and a
bunch of friends
um and I wonder you know how do you
blend the two could you offset
homeschooling with
a different sports club every single
night
um to try and get that degree of
socialization exposure to different
cultures different people different
situations very difficult I mean you
know Ryan Terry is kids sounds like is
basically on a pro athlete's training
schedule like five or six days a week
gymnastics swimming karate like each
different night yeah
but I don't know man this is a whole
Uncharted Territory at the moment and
um the fact that you've got twins is
just going to be such a fascinating
experiment for you to watch
and we're gonna hopefully touch wood
have a lot more kids as well we all have
a big family and again that's important
to me and certainly to Robin as well
having a big family have been honest you
mentioned that your misses might want a
slightly bigger family than you'd
anticipated I thought three weeks after
the birth when chaos was at its all-time
high that she would have tapered her
Ambitions but she still definitely wants
four or five kids so apparently
it is the people have a genetic
predisposition to having twins as well
uh Matt Walsh guy that works for the
daily wire I think he's six kids deep
but that's only been four births he's
had like two pairs of twins in that so
you could be also my business partner
Darren he'd had two and he wasn't sure
they were like talking should we have a
third should we not have a third and
that is Mrs it said like I really want
to have one uh and he realized up until
they had the scan he's like [__] we
could go from two to four here uh and he
wasn't ready for he would have to have
changed the car he would have they would
have to have immediately bought a new
house all hell would have broken loose
so just you know think think carefully
moving forward
um what are you looking to do over the
next few years like personally in terms
of the things that you want to develop
the ways that you want to learn about
yourself about the world impact that you
want to have what's your focus going to
be do you think over the next few years
um well clearly by professional focus is
solely on gym shark and building gym
shark out into a great business we're at
this
peculiar point now where we're trying to
transition into a really
Global business where
like at the moment we I mean we sell
globally but we're not a true Global
business so we're trying to really
develop that and we've just just hired
in and built like a new leadership team
that uh I think the last person joined
in January so a fairly fresh new team so
that's important to me like betting that
in and making sure the business is ready
for the next phase of growth uh
personally I just want to get settled in
a forever home and get that finished and
nice and done that will take a year or
two hope well hopefully not not two so
12 18 months
um I think as well I I know we've spoken
about this previously but I would be
interested in
how and whether my content develops into
speaking more openly about maybe some of
the things that we've spoken about today
without being overly involved in
politics especially not American
politics because I am not I'm not an
American and I know that a brick talking
about American politics generally
doesn't end particularly positively so
um but I guess more around the way that
the UK is shaping up especially from a
commercial perspective because I think
I've got value to add there so I would
definitely consider how I can talk more
openly about those things have you ever
been offered you've spoken on boards and
stuff would you ever take a more formal
role no no I wouldn't have time now I've
been offered lots of board seats and
involvement into lots of things the only
thing I've ever said yesterday would be
the the government's business Advisory
Board the only area that I would take
time to contribute would be to
the UK government whoever it is and to
be honest I'm sort of agnostic as to who
it is because I don't feel as though I
would be contributing to them as
individuals I'd be contributing to the
sister as a whole yeah which I think is
beneficial regardless of who's there
Ben Francis ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do where should they go
uh YouTube search Ben Francis on YouTube
Instagram all the usual social medias
Ben I appreciate you thank you mate
thank you very much what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]